if we look at the Bible today and people
watching this is a challenge for anybody
watching bring the pope any Minister any
preacher any Christian Evangelical bring
a Bible scholar and put him in front of
me and see any one of them that can
recite the Bible verse by verse letter
by letter one in the whole two billion
strong challenge let's do it all right
I'll fly to the Vatican myself giving
dawah since the mid 90s and we've put
this challenge out we've had every
Christian Evangelical islamophobe fly
from the UK and across the U.S you know
who we are I don't know who you are why
would you assume I know who you are are
you famous to come to San Diego and
challenge us till today they have not
been able to produce one single person
that is memorized about but the Sheikh
has from Egypt really asked him in Egypt
how many people they memorize the Quran
throw a rock you hit three of them